i really started growing my business and
i started scaling up and i started you
know really talking more about more
advanced strategies or things that
beginners maybe aren't ready for yet and
i i was disconnected in that sense and
so having that survey especially as i've
scaled up especially as i've grown was
one of the key ways for me to get back
in touch and like understand what was it
like again to be someone who's starting
out
are you ready to grow your youtube
channel this year if the answer to that
is yes then i want to help you actually
go straight to the source that is doing
customer surveys in today's episode
we're going to be talking all about the
value of surveying your audience to be
able to know what type of video content
you should make know what's working and
what's not working and get an insight
into how you're actually helping your
audience move forward my name is heather
torres i'm the host of this think media
podcast the number one podcast to help
you grow your influence on youtube and
then turn that influence into a high
impact and a high profit youtube channel
and if you're brand new to the podcast
we want to welcome you to the think fam
we love to see every single week your
comments and your reviews on the podcast
so if you're brand new i want to say
welcome introduce yourself down in the
comments below if you're watching on
youtube or if you like this type of
content you can leave a review over on
apple podcast well before we jump into
today's episode i do want to tell you
about an amazing sponsor that we have
for this podcast and that is a way for
you to be able to conduct your own video
podcast just like this recording your
video podcast with anyone from around
the world has never been easier you can
send a link for up to nine people and
they can immediately start recording
using their own computers no extra
equipment or downloads required with
each of your guests they actually are
recording locally and it's studio
quality tracks where editing becomes a
breeze you can split trim fade and
arrange each of the tracks to your
heart's content and then you can use
podcastl's ai powered magic dust tool to
automatically sweeten and equalize the
mix you make it sound really good and
look really great you can invite record
edit and polish all using podcasts and
if you want to get started today for
free you can go to
podcastwiththink.com now we are diving
back into a three-part series that we
did with fellow youtuber and
entrepreneur vanessa lau during the
first part of the conversation we talked
all about how she broke her youtube
channel what she learned from it and
what steps she's taken to move forward
in the second part of the interview we
talked about the five analytics that can
help you grow not just your youtube
channel but your online business and
then in today's episode we're diving
into how she used customer surveys to
really start to understand who our
audience was and how she could help them
more so we're gonna jump into the middle
of the conversation that shawn and
vanessa lau had about surveying her
audience and then afterwards i have five
tips for you for getting started with
your first survey
[Music]
let's unpack that a little bit because
you know one of the things we encourage
think media podcast listeners to do is
to really understand their audience's
problems and ambitions that's a
never-ending
um journey and you mentioned this survey
i'm curious um
the the technical side how did you share
it how did you host it did you keep it
simple um and is there any other ways
you try to stay in touch with your
community that our listeners could do to
get a better pulse and maybe what kind
of content they should be creating
whether or not they're even making an
impact or they're completely out of
touch and so uh unpack that a little bit
for us
yeah i actually want to take a step back
i love how you said out of touch because
that's how i felt with my channel and i
think that's how like a good portion of
my audience might have felt too is like
you get so consumed in creating content
and especially if you've done it for a
while you kind of assume you know
everything you're like i know what they
want this is what they want or maybe you
outgrow like the the initial audience
that you might have attracted so for
example for me
when i started my business and i still
create content it's very it's very
beginner friendly it's really for people
who are starting from scratch but for me
me personally i really started growing
my business and i started scaling up and
i started you know really talking more
about more advanced strategies or things
that
beginners maybe aren't ready for yet and
i i was disconnected in that sense and
so having that survey especially as i've
scaled up especially as i've grown was
one of the key ways for me to get back
in touch and like understand what was it
like again to be someone who's starting
out what are the questions that they
have because i might think that it's an
elementary question and like you know
what like no one's gonna everyone knows
this answer everyone knows this but no i
know this but the people that watch my
channel don't know this and sometimes as
a content creator especially if you've
done so much content you forget about it
because you've repeated yourself so many
times and you feel like okay well i've
already talked like about how to get
your first 1000 followers on instagram
so now i'm going to talk about how to
get 200 000 followers on instagram
because that's where i'm at right now
but like come on 90 of my audience does
not have 200 000 followers they just
want their first 1000. and i need to
keep repeating that and share that like
and really focus on that and so
that's one thing that prompted me to do
that survey and so logistically how i
did it was i um
it was really easy like i just came up
with a few questions to ask um and then
i put in a google doc kind of got my
team to review it um and then afterwards
we put it on a type form so a type form
is basically a software that you can use
it's like you can use surveymonkey you
can use anything i use typeform you can
use a google like google questionnaire
form as well just any type of form um
and then i just shared it with my
audience i posted it on instagram and i
said hey guys like i really want to know
more about what you guys want from me
and obviously in exchange for your time
if you fill out the survey at the end
you're gonna get a special link to an
exclusive training that i have about
like instagram stories or something so i
gave people something in return and i
think that's what led to me getting a
lot of responses and i think this is
important advice especially if you maybe
have a smaller audience or you're just
starting out is asking someone to fill
out a survey especially if it's a
comprehensive one like maybe it's one
that has more than 10 questions is
time-consuming and if you want your
survey to be successful and if you want
a higher response rate you gotta
exchange value for it and it and if
you're already creating content anyways
just like give them an exclusive piece
of content so that at the end of it they
get rewarded for that um and so that was
how logistically we did it and we also
wanted to keep the survey anonymous so
you might be wondering well how did you
actually give them the training if it
was anonymous and all of that um what we
did was we we told everyone was
anonymous so that they could be honest
with me
because i wanted that honesty and then
at the end when they're done the survey
there was a thank you page that would
pop up and the thank you page would have
the secret link to the private training
um
and
that was that then they were able to
access the training from there and the
survey was kept anonymous i got all the
results i needed it was a win-win for
everyone um and that's kind of how i did
it now if you don't want to go the
avenue of having a survey i still think
you should to be honest but you don't
have to have a survey every single month
i think it's maybe like
once every two quarters type of thing
because
having too much feedback sometimes can
also be a bit overwhelming as a content
creator but just like simple things
paying attention to your comments
section
looking at your dm's if you have a team
and you've outsourced that a lot then
maybe get your team to fill you in or
maybe at some point in your business you
kind of hop in yourself and look at the
comments or whatever else like there's
there's a lot there's a lot of clues
your audience does try to tell you stuff
you just have to pay attention to it
man the creator who understands the
viewer best wins
and um it could be so easy you really
dropped some powerful insights there i
think our action item of the week is
survey your audience i mean get in touch
and ask yourself and self-reflect are
you maybe out of touch what's
interesting is here at think media i
suppose this the first video was uh ever
uploaded on the channel in 2010 so 11 12
years into this thing
i think
the wrong conclusion would be oh i get
it now oh i know now or i understand
where people are at just like you said
but we try to always remind ourselves
and try to be kind of forever students
and free of forever beginners in our own
mind of understanding who's watching how
can we help what are their pain points
what words are they using
you know and one of the biggest bombs
you just dropped
was where you are
might not be where your audience is in
fact it probably isn't and chances are
if you're listening to this podcast you
might be growing a lot faster even than
those that you're helping and so you
feel like if you've progressed in the
last three to six months you've you read
six books listened to this podcast every
week attended a conference you know and
you're like oh yeah i assume everyone's
they're probably you know in step with
me or similar to what i'm not
necessarily maybe it depends on the
niche depends on what you're doing but
actually chances are
you might be growing at a lot faster
rate you you map that out over a couple
years because we've discovered the same
we start wanting to talk about the
latest things we've learned in the
latest things that we're so excited
about when in fact those topics might
not actually be the most relevant topics
for the core
individuals that we're helping at the
highest levels or we get so niched into
intermediate maybe advanced content and
your views could go down
maybe that's okay if that was a
strategic decision because it's always
going to be a smaller audience that's
intermediate or advanced however if
you're just doing that because you just
assume your audience is coming along
with you man assumptions could be one of
the biggest enemies that could cause us
to uh you know have our views drop or
start getting as you said out of
touch and so i hope we can all implement
a survey um and you know i've heard of
mentors i follow they try to do an
annual listener or reader or viewer
survey at least an annual one that's
they kind of make a big deal maybe give
away some gift cards or you know to
three people at the end or i love the
training idea i imagine we'll be doing
that in the next four weeks that will
all be launched and out because uh
that's a that's a great and we were
already kind of had it in our queue to
do one but i think we'll give away a
free um training at the end of the day
oh it worked super well i was like
i don't even know if i'm gonna get like
100 people we ended up like we i think
we set the max like okay the first like
once we get 100 we're going to shut down
the survey within like less than i don't
know six hours it was like in the
thousands because everyone wanted that
training so definitely recommend that i
also want to add into something um when
it comes like beginner in advance
sometimes i also find that you have to
this is where like social media
platforms come into play
um
and it might not be a hunt like what i'm
saying might not be a hundred percent
accurate but i also find that
at least in my experience it almost
feels like the more advanced content
that you do sometimes youtube like may
not be the best platform to share that
because you also think like
okay let's say if i'm sharing advice to
help someone in the seven figure level
you know i'm not 100 sure if someone at
the seven figure level is using youtube
to find content for them to grow their
seven-figure business maybe they're
actually looking into podcasts or maybe
they're looking into a blog like like
googling something or like something
else and so i think it's also sometimes
important to understand especially in
your survey like where your audience is
hanging out and how they get their
source of information and what level
they're at in their knowledge and you're
able to kind of gauge and ch like
separate you know advanced content from
beginner content figure out what
platforms for what purpose and who
you're trying to attract with a certain
platform that's at least what i've
noticed so far for me those are some
very nuanced insights and some
considerations vanessa as we land the
plane today let's kind of
futurecast a little bit especially along
this subject of we're all now making
plans we're making plans of what can we
change
if we feel like our youtube channel is
broken
what maybe is some external factors we
need to just give ourselves some grace
and put things in perspective but then
of course we also need to always be
evolving the reality of this industry is
it is highly competitive in a way you
say what isn't though i mean it's in a
way like life and business is evolving
the market is evolving consumer interest
is evolving um and so i'm curious with a
couple final questions
what do you personally do to spot trends
in business and social media do you have
routines do you have a particular things
what do you listen to what do you read
um how do you do are you even concerned
with maybe spotting trends or do you
find that the fundamentals are are the
most important things how important
being on the bleeding edge or cutting
edge of business or social media is it
to it i'm just curious the vanessa lao
secrets to uh stay on the cutting edge
yeah i i don't necessarily
go into trends that much to be honest um
until my audience until until i start
hearing the questions pour in so for
example like yes let's say tick-tock was
trending but at the time i didn't hear
anyone in my audience ask me personally
my opinion on it and so i'm like okay
well
that's not something that maybe i might
dive into versus eventually more and
more and more people started dming me
about it there was a demand
i think that's what's important is like
i really pay attention to what my
audience
demands are
and i kind of gauge if that
if that makes sense for me to talk about
it or to step into it and the reason why
i'm saying if that makes sense for me is
because i think that it's a bit
dangerous if you're if your growth
strategy is top on trends
because
there are going to be some trends that
come and go
and at the same time too there's also
trends that yeah sure are trendy but you
might not be wanna be like you might not
want to be known for that trend like
what if like i always think about like i
always kind of put a think of a scenario
where like okay let's say um the topic
of
cows are trending right now
and i create a video about cows if that
video goes viral do i want to be known
as the cowgirl
i don't think so
so probably not for me or like a good
example that i could bring up that was
very specific to me because i was
debating like should i talk about it
should i not talk about was clubhouse
clubhouse was a platform that was
popping off um you know during the
pandemic and i was like oh wow and i did
see people asking me about it but at the
heart of it i i wasn't even using
clubhouse and i personally am a very
like video person
i'm not very good at like audio
auditory stuff like i'm not very good
listener i need to see someone that's
why like for zoom meetings if someone's
camera's off it's very it's actually
very challenging for me to process the
information and so
just as a person i was like oh i
personally don't think i would be using
clubhouse myself as much
um and so
i i thought about it and then i also
asked myself okay if i if i do talk
about clubhouse and that video takes off
or like if people want more of that
would i actually be happy with that or
like would i want to be known
to to pivot that way probably not and so
i i didn't talk about it um or i didn't
like
promote it as much and
lo and behold i don't think clubhouse is
as popular as before and so i'm really
glad i followed my intuition on that one
and so i kind of pick and choose
um but definitely i look at a mix of
demand and a mix of does this fit with
like what i what i genuinely am
interested in sharing and talking about
brilliant now as we approach uh 2022 and
are even in a new year
what uh is on your mind in
in response to your video i messed up my
youtube channel in response to maybe
some of the changes you've made
um and maybe just what are some of the
details of your personal youtube
uh game plan this is another chance to
of course let our community know about
what you're doing
and so they could follow you i did see
that similar to think media you launched
a podcast channel you moved your content
to
a podcast channel we are
in love with video podcasting to your
point i'm similar youtube is my favorite
platform to consume as a youtube premium
user
i i love it when podcasts are on youtube
because i'll listen to them just in
audio sometimes i could be in my pocket
or then i pull my phone out now i'm
standing in line at the bank or
something and i'm able to look at my
phone and so yeah what are what are some
what is your kind of cadence what's a
little bit of your youtube game plan and
what are some of the places people can
follow you to stay connected with what
you're doing right now
yeah i think right now i'm focusing more
on youtube we did have a good run with
the podcast um but i have since learned
i personally don't think at least like
where my company is at and where my time
is spent and the infrastructure and the
offers that we have and people that
we're trying to target that it's a good
time at least in this season to like go
all in on my podcast because i had the
same problem where this is when i
launched my podcast um i think it was
like the second time i launched it and i
still felt like burnt out and that's
kind of when i realized i haven't
mastered my workflow for youtube yet to
be honest like if i'm adding on this
extra platform and it's adding this much
more pressure
i don't it tells me that something in
the workflow
needs some trimming down it needs some
more streamlining and it kind of goes
back to what we were talking about
before with batching is like still
trying like three years in and i'm still
trying to find my secret sauce when it
comes to a workflow that works for me
that allows me to be consistent
allows me to not lose my mind um with
video uh for youtube and so for me
personally know it especially with the
survey that we got and it was just so
clear to me that youtube is our bread
and butter i'm gonna be spending more
time on that um another thing too in
terms of like maybe trend or strategy or
whatever else is focusing a little bit
more on shorter form content is what i'm
doing personally because you know
i don't know if you saw in the news or
whatever else but tick tock has
overtaken youtube in some sense of
people spending more time on that
platform and to me that doesn't tell me
to like not do youtube anymore i think
that's a huge i think youtube has its
own place but it tells me that people do
like shorter form content and i think
it's kind of getting in that direction
especially you know as people are
hanging out like
people just love that micro content
piece pieces and so what i'm focusing on
is maybe trimming down some of my
youtube content and experimenting with
it i think the word experiment is key so
everything i say here at least in this
answer it's me experimenting um because
what i notice is a lot of my videos are
20 minutes long some some of them are 30
minutes long and when i look at the data
the average view duration is like people
aren't watching half of the like they're
not even watching over half of the video
and so what i'm personally focusing on
is trying to be more concise in my
videos and try to get it more get get
the information there in a more snappy
way not feel like i need to over
elaborate or over explain all the time
really focusing on how can i make sure
that people are getting the information
in
in the least not the least amount of
time possible but in a in a very
efficient way that's kind of what i'm
experimenting with right now on my
channel
some really powerful insights that i
think we can apply to uh
let our listeners know about that study
an app analytics firm discovered that
americans spend more time on tick tock
as of june 2021 they're watching an
average of 24 hours of content per month
on tik tok versus only 22 hours and 40
minutes a month on youtube statistics
only account for android users in the
united states
and the total watch time of course is
dramatically higher on youtube because
there's still more users but
nevertheless that is a
massive data point that signals to us
that uh tick-tock tick-tock being short
form and i think um youtube's answer or
counter or
one of the things they're doing in
response to that is tick tock has tick
tock and instagram has reels and now
youtube has shorts
and uh short form content is something
that would be i think irresponsible for
us to ignore
as uh on or unwise for us to ignore um
in terms of where things are going and i
love how you said
that
is influencing your
full-length youtube videos as well it's
a lot we do the same we do a lot of
deeper trainings
it could we could go 30 minutes we could
go 40 i have 4 45 55-minute youtube
videos even cutting that in half is so
significant in a world where a lot of
people are uh enjoying 15 to 30 second
uh short form content as well think
media listeners if you happen to be on
youtube i would be curious about what
your strategy is for
uh 2022 are you leaning into short form
leave us a comment and what is your
thoughts on short form overtaking long
form content no matter where you're
listening to this if you've been getting
value out of the podcast please uh rate
and review on apple podcasts uh we
appreciate it and then vanessa
youtube your main channel that's where
we can follow you to get some value and
then on instagram um where are you at
yep you can just type in vanessalau dot
co i'm sure if you type in vanessa i'll
be the first one that shows up
amazing well thank you so much for
coming on to the podcast today and
adding so much value to our community
thank you for having me it was a
pleasure having all these strategy chats
with you
well i hope that part of the
conversation that shawn and vanessa had
brought you value and i want to jump
into um five tips for you as you are
creating your first survey you know here
at think media if you've been a part of
our family for a while you've probably
seen one of our surveys we try to
intentionally do this at least once a
year inside of our courses and also to
our wider community our youtube audience
and our social media audience and
there's a couple things that we've
learned over the years when it comes to
actually setting up a good survey so tip
number one is you want to actually have
a goal in mind what are you actually
trying to accomplish with this survey i
loved how vanessa said in hers that she
was really wanted to figure out what
video ideas should she be doing what is
making people want to come and how did
they come to her content what's keeping
them there right having a goal in mind
is really important what are you trying
to get out of the audience what
information are you trying to source
from them i also like the goal that
vanessa had of actually how many surveys
was she trying to get what sample size
was she looking for and you know she
said that within just a few hours they
had exceeded their goal so set realistic
goals for yourself based on your
audience size but really be thinking
about that do you want 50 spot responses
are you looking for a thousand are you
looking for 10 000 and then figuring out
how are you going to get that response
is really important so that's tip number
one number two is you want to actually
ask the right questions so here at think
media we like to do what are called
leading questions open-ended questions
so rather than someone answering with a
yes or a no actually give them space to
fill in the content for you what does
this mean it means something like tell
me about where you're struggling on
youtube and when they tell you about
that they're actually going to be using
the words that you can then speak back
to them in your videos so if someone
were to fill that out for us here at
think media tell me about where you're
struggling with youtube it could be
something like i just don't feel like i
have enough time to make youtube happen
i don't really know how youtube works
i'm really trying to figure out what my
thing is right and instead of saying
things like i want to improve my time
management skills or i don't really know
what my niche is they're actually using
words that a normal person would use not
a marketer like we are so actually
understanding what your audience is
saying where their pain points are is
really key
number three is you wanna maybe have
some nice to knows now the most
important things are the actual answers
to the questions but maybe some nice to
knows are how long have you been
following me or what is your name
if you want it to be anonymous like
vanessa did maybe you're not asking that
but if you do want to know what their
name is maybe you're asking for their
phone number as well if you want to put
them on a text message list you decide
what the nice to know content is that
you want but instead of just getting the
answers from them also maybe think about
how can i get to know them more so maybe
a nice to know for you could be what is
your email address so i can send you
that private link like vanessa did the
fourth tip for you would be to encourage
them to take action vanessa did this so
well when she asked them for their
survey in exchange for limited content
or exclusive content to what she was
doing this is something we've done here
at think media before you can enter in
the survey and enter to win something
like for us a youtube studio but i think
one of the first surveys we did here at
think media when it was just sean
heather and omar and we were just trying
to figure this whole thing out i think
we did a 20 amazon gift card i mean it
wasn't crazy but it was something that
was able to give back to the audience or
maybe it could be something like a
hundred dollar starbucks gift card you
decide what it is and what works best
for you if you already have something
that you could give away maybe it's a
low end course or a module to something
or maybe it's a download that they could
have you decide what that is but you're
going to want to encourage someone to
take action why because people are
bombarded with a lot of things all day
long so you need to incentivize them to
be giving something back to you you are
asking something big of them you're
asking for their time and so in exchange
you want to give them something in
return so that they will give you their
time you can get the answers you need
and you can help them in the future and
tip number five is that you want to use
this data please do not take a survey of
your audience and then not actually read
it this is where you want to set aside
time to dig through the answers maybe
even print them out and get a
highlighter and highlight words that
you're seeing over and over again
highlight struggles that you're seeing
over and over again really use the data
maybe you thought that your audience was
actually more advanced than they were
like vanessa's she was moving fast but
her audience was actually still at the
beginning stage so maybe it's actually a
check on you to figure out wow i'm
moving faster than my audience is or
like she said i'm maybe not even putting
the right content on the right platforms
so use the data wisely and i would just
say that you know when it comes to
surveying your audience there is no
better gold than going right to the
source if you know who you want to help
and you know how you can help them
you are in the right place if you are
asking people questions that will help
you get to those two things who do you
help and how do you help them well i
hope you enjoyed the conversation with
vanessa and let us know if you're
watching on youtube what other content
creators would you like us to bring here
on the podcast i always love to see who
you're following and whose brain you'd
like us to pick so let us know if you're
watching on youtube and i'd love to
maybe bring that content creator on now
if you are already subscribed here on
the podcast i want to say thank you so
much for being a part of the family
again it means so much to us that you
tune in every single tuesday for the
think media podcast that hashtag tuesday
ritual is so important to us and i love
to highlight different people who have
been leaving reviews and rating the
podcast over on apple podcast it means
the world to us that you are there
leaving those reviews to help other
people learn if this is the right place
for them and today's review comes from
alan allen says i'm starting a podcast
awesome alan this week i have listened
to you guys for about four days and i've
gotten so much out of it i've been going
between youtube and the podcast i had
already had some prep work going for my
podcast but listening to you guys tells
me i'm going to start it it launches on
friday thank you thank you thank you
well alan i'm reading this and it looks
like you left that review on february
1st so i want to congratulate you for
starting your podcast it's such a fun
way to get to go deeper with your
audience and alan i want to just say
thank you for being a part of what we're
doing here we appreciate you so much and
i am so excited for your future on
youtube and in your podcast world well i
want to say thank you for listening to
today's episode you can catch all of our
latest episodes on apple podcast or on
our youtube channel spotify wherever you
listen to
your audio at we are there and i cannot
wait to bring you all of the content we
have scheduled for this year we'll catch
you in the next episode